and this afternoon small businesses
started celebrating
as we usher in a new era of this
pandemic fight hector mejia is live this
afternoon near buffalo and flamingo with
the story hector
well lunch and celebrating the end of
coronavirus restrictions here in clark
county got underway
right at noon this is a group of local
women in the restaurant industry
representing more than a dozen local
places celebrating las vegas
returning to 100 capacity we are at
dagostino's trotteria
where they're networking and they tell
us full capacity means they no longer
have to split
large groups of people who wish to sit
together
so june 1st is a day to celebrate for
many restaurants that are still
recovering from pandemic restrictions as
of today clark county's pandemic
guidelines are now
in the rear view mirror leaders allowed
covet 19
rules to expire right at midnight no
more restrictions on capacity
social distancing large gatherings
dancing
and face masks for those who are fully
vaccinated
increasing vaccination rates a low
positivity rate
and pre-pandemic hospitalizations all
gave way to this day
i feel like maybe it's not quite over
yet but we're going to celebrate that it
is
so i think moving forward
people are just going to still feel a
little bit different coming out
you know they still peek through the
door and go do i have to wear a mask
if skate of cases spike and hospitals
start having capacity
issues the governor or clark county
could rewind things and reinstate limits
all over again
cdc guidance still requires masks inside
hospitals
and on public transportation including
planes
buses and trains and here's one more
thing to note as we move forward right
now individual businesses
can still ask and can still ask
employees and customers
to wear a mask reporting near flamingo
and buffalo hector mejia
8 news now